the inspectors had no comment when they
arrived at their Damascus hotel their
findings could have major consequences a
year ago the US said that the use of
chemical weapons would trigger action we
have been very clear to the Assad regime
but also to other players on the ground
that a red line for us is we start
seeing a whole bunch of chemical weapons
moving around or being utilized this
video is said to show the victims of a
gas attack both sides have accused the
other of using chemical agents there are
many anecdotal accounts there was a
smell so we went out I felt dizzy in my
eyes turned red despite mounting
evidence of chemical weapons use the US
has not taken action yet there has not
been even a hint of military
intervention so far the inspectors
mission is to conduct an independent
analysis of whether such weapons were
deployed at all not who is responsible
they'll investigate three sites over a
two-week visit some in the opposition
see the arrival of the inspectors as a
hopeful sign evidence of chemical
warfare might bring more international
support to their cause